- I am like 99% sure
that there is some sort of
infectious disease in this kitchen.
(upbeat acoustic music)
Hey everybody, my name's Ashley
and today I have a little bit
of an unusual video for you,
it is a clean with me video.
Maybe you've heard of
them, maybe you haven't.
I just discovered them recently
and I am totally hooked.
They are basically vlogs of
people cleaning their houses.
I know what you're thinking,
hmm, that sounds more boring
than actually cleaning.
But I promise for some reason it is not.
They are totally mesmerizing.
I am completely hooked.
I can't stop watching.
Now, all I wanna do is clean my apartment.
I'm gonna take you guys
along for the ride.
I hope you enjoy, I hope it inspires you
to maybe clean one of your own spaces
and yeah, I got a lot of work to do,
so let's go get scrubbing.
(upbeat acoustic music)
This is why I'm emptying
the entire kitchen first,
things like this soap scum and stuff,
I would have never even noticed
if I hadn't removed the soap container,
the dish rack, and all those things.
You just don't realize the scum and stuff
that is building up in your life.
(bell chiming)
(upbeat acoustic music)
The kitchen is empty,
it's looking pretty good
and now it is time for admittedly
my least favorite part of this whole thing
and that is scrubbing and sanitizing.
(mellow electronic music)
(electronic beeping)
Okay, let's see if that
worked, I don't know.
(gasps)
Whoa, okay, this hack is a good one.
(mellow electronic music)
(upbeat acoustic music)
(bells chiming)
It is time to start my
all-time favorite part
of any deep clean, organizing.
(bells chiming)
(upbeat soft rock music)
(upbeat acoustic music)
(squeaking)